how many of you actually let me go with
this angle how many of you know my spiel
or know who I am raise your hand that
hurts all right so then I'll give a
little context and I'll kind of go into
some Q&A hopefully my background is that
I come from a family liquor store
business so I I was born in Russia I
came to the US and my dad got a job as a
stock boy in a liquor store and kind of
grew from there and eventually owned it
I was super entrepreneurial and then I
got involved in that liquor store when I
was 14 and somewhere around 16 I fell in
love with wine I was able to take over
my dad's business when I was 22 and from
1998 to 2003 for five and that's six
seven year window I grew it from a three
to a sixty five million dollar business
I did that basically on the backbone of
innovating around storytelling uh and
back then it was just having a dot-com
in 96 for a local liquor store and then
it evolved into you know search and
banner and things of that nature
I eventually then started a youtube show
that kind of made me internet famous and
led to a lot of opportunities which
ultimately led me to three years ago
starting an agency with my brother AJ
originally we were basically predicated
on doing community management two years
ago we started creating micro content
which is what I think a lot of the
conversation is now about for me
standing up here thinking about who's in
the crowd and what this conference is
about is is interesting because I think
that what this all kind of Nets out at
and everything that you've heard here
today and everything I'm about to say
that information is pretty commodity
most of you have heard it most of you
have read it I think what's more
interesting to me is the lack of
execution around it right so I think a
lot of us understand this is happening
and I think a lot of us talk about it
but the stunning lack of execution in
the marketplace and the overwhelming
let's just do what we've always done has
always been the thing that's been most
shocking to me in the three years that
I've been involved in corporate and
working with big brands Paul Markham who
was here earlier is a client of ours we
do the content for them on their social
networks I think the most interesting
thing is you know I sit here and I see
refinery29
I remember when I saw that three or four
years ago I'm like oh [ __ ] these guys
are starting to get it this kind of
commerce content all of this stuff is
starting to bleed together and I think
when you sum this whole thing up
this whole day this whole movement this
whole conversation the first thing I
would say is this I think all of us in
this room and pretty much all of us
outside of this room in this world
recognized that 99.9 percent of the ads
are straight [ __ ] mainly because they
bring no value just like when I was kind
of growing up in the last couple years
around angel investing and investing in
a lot of companies the companies that
I'm always looking to invest in have to
solve some problem or bring some value
and I think that the biggest problem
that we've had in the space for a long
time is most of these things are not
bringing us any value and I think the
opportunity for native ads real-time ads
any any way you want to put it is how
are we as storytellers for our brands or
businesses going to find a way to bring
some sort of value to the end consumer
and and the funny part is I actually
think the number one place to focus on
in that is escapism right a lot of
people here watch TV watch movies listen
to music watch New York Jets games
strictly to get away from the fact that
our world is complicated and intense and
I think that escapism is a real huge
opportunity in the world that I live in
so my company is very focused on how the
hell do we story tell in a world that
looks like this so fast and I go back to
thinking about this historically so I
think about the Leo Burnett company and
what they did in the 50s and 60s and I
think they kind of figured it out and I
think it's why they had so much success
they've understood the psychology of the
consumer sitting on their couch watching
The Mary Tyler Moore Show and realized
that those people during that era during
that time in a captive way we're
interested in characters and stories and
so they decided during the break when we
were being intrusive which is all we've
ever done in advertising for the last
hundred years up into this moment where
it's now being debated in that intrusive
moment when we stopped them from doing
what they naturally wanted to do they
decided to piggyback on the thesis
psychologically they gave you more
characters they gave you the Jolly Green
Giant and
Tony the Tiger they gave you the Keebler
elves and the Marlboro Man and they
understood the psychology of what you
were doing when you were sitting on your
ass in your home captive and not getting
up unless you were taking a piss right
and so I think that what we need to do
in this market today is do the same
exact thing why are we captivated by
meme culture why are we scanning through
our news feeds so quickly what value are
we getting at if they're out of a quick
laugh or a chuckle or why in the world
do some of the most engaged pieces of
content I put out our content of like
find the little character in the
background of these pictures
it's an essence literally things that we
used to do when we were five and six in
kindergarten yet consumers like it
because they're most often bored or
trying to escape and and I think that
what I'm most fascinated about is this
it all ends and starts with storytelling
and I think that for me when I think
about native ads is how do I story tell
in the mindset of the consumer so great
I heard you know the panel before me and
it's it's wonderful to show a banner ad
or during the time I do think time has a
lot of value and I think that's really
important but I think that we need to
start digging a little bit deeper into
the psychology of why they're there in
the first place nobody goes to a website
to then look on the right side of a
website see a banner ad and click it
right
most people don't watch television shows
for the sake of watching the commercials
all we've done collectively as an
industry for a hundred years is [ __ ]
people up from what they actually wanted
to do and I think that it's collectively
everybody's job now because there's so
many alternatives and there's so many
more opportunities for us to figure out
how to add value to the overall
experience whether that makes them laugh
whether it gives them a utility you know
I think that there's a huge amount of
that and so for me I'm starting to think
about how do we problem-solve where
we're actually solving business problems
around content the two things that I'm
really driven by today that continue to
go in my head over and over and over
again is why in the hell did Guinness
when they figured out that they had pub
pours down for the first time ever 50
years ago go to pubs figure out what
people
talking about and then decide to launch
the Guinness Book of World Records
because they figured that because trivia
was the number one thing that people
talked about in pubs that if they could
own that story and get people to talk
about those things that it would elude
them to go and buy beer why did they go
there and what is the 2013 version of
that why did Michelin a hundred years
ago decide to solve their business
problem of people in cities not driving
enough so they weren't wearing down
their tires and so why do they decide to
start story telling about the hotels and
the restaurants in the suburbs and the
countryside to get people to drive and
then that's why the Michelin star system
today dominates outside the u.s. the
authority around where you go and eat
and where you stay when you go on
vacation these are two companies a long
time before awesome smart asses that
figured out that if we could just bring
some sort of value in addition and solve
some sort of problem that there's a way
for us to kind of own that thought that
conversation that psychological sector
of that consumers mind and then benefit
as a brand from that I think that that
is a challenge for all of us it's why
I've always paid attention to this
company refinery29 pointing here's a
sign and why really why the only reason
I'm sitting here is quite simple the
reason I'm sitting here is yeah okay I
built a 60 million dollar ecommerce wine
business but a lot of people have done
that what I did when I saw YouTube come
out was I saw another platform that
allowed me to story tell and so I
decided one day in 2006 nine months
after they launched to take one of my
stock boys and send them to Best Buy he
brought back a camera I sat in front of
a table put four bottles of wine on it
and drank them for the next twenty
minutes and recorded it and put it out
there and realized very quickly why only
twelve months later or four hundred
thousand people a day we're watching it
because I did something I brought value
and here was the value by show of hands
and I know you're tired how many people
here are into wine or have a friend or
family member that is fairly into wine
raise your hand
very nice most of you so then you will
know this the second somebody gets even
a little bit of wine knowledge they
become a straight
douchebag so what I did in 2006 it's
true thank you it's true right
well what why did you order that year
cuz I [ __ ] love a [ __ ] you know
what I did in 2006 was I became the
first person in that world to talk to
people about wine instead of down to
them and that was the value that I
brought I made a bunch of people that
drank beer or watched wrestling or
didn't or crumbled when a wine list was
put in front of them at a business
meeting start getting confident and made
them better wine drinkers just like oh
by the way the reason that Instagram
sold for a billion dollars was because
they made us take better pictures
they brought value and so I
fundamentally asked the advertising
world the native world whatever the [ __ ]
we call this to think about at the end
of the day we completely for the last
100 years collectively have massively
disrespected the end consumer and we've
tried to figure out ways to shove [ __ ]
down their throats when they didn't want
them and the shift and the opportunity
right now with the conversation that
we're having is how do we start working
a little bit harder and stop worrying
about scale and start realizing that not
all impressions are equal and start
figuring out how to bring some sort of
value to the end consumer so that they
actually could care about the brand and
the context of that brand impression
actually may want them to do something
which is oh by the way at the end of day
we're here to sell [ __ ] and make them do
things and the way to do that is to care
about them first you love your parents
because they loved you first it's time
for us to care about our customers first
and I think we need to figure out ways
to do it and I think that we've never
had more opportunity to do it we have
plenty of data and we know we have tons
of data but this is all predicated on
one thing when is this group and this
world gonna start executing around this
thing that we all know works
dramatically better than the 99% of the
other [ __ ] that we do that is dumb and
brings zero value to the end consumer
thank you
got time for some Q&A so I'm really
hoping for some Q&A cuz I think that
just brings so much more value so does
anybody have a question awesome
hey Gary my calf knee from share through
like when you talk about value and data
how much of the data we have access to
unlimited amount of data how much is it
that is the value is a hundred percent
of it valuable is it ten percent of that
data valuable I mean you know the weird
thing for me is is I don't I'm stunned
you know again I come from like selling
lemonade and baseball cards and wine so
now I come into and I have a lot of
clients at our CPG clients and I'm just
always stunned and you a lot of people
here are much more tenured and
understand this better than I do I'm
fairly new to the corporate world I'm
just stunned how many people forget like
what they're trying to do for a living
right like we just get so on these
tangents and it gets so inside marketing
baseball I call it you know we just talk
about our terminology I mean the data's
as valuable as you want to make it as
long as you actually understand what
you're trying to achieve so like the
clients that are most happy with the
work that I'm doing by producing micro
content for social networks are the ones
that are ecommerce like Green Mountain
coffee they know how many K cups they
sell because of our micro content and so
I'm writing a new book called Jab Jab
Jab right hook and it talks about the
formula of like setting this up because
most of us in this room and in the world
are in right hook right hook right hook
right hook mode Oh ease pushing so we
need to find how to bring value I think
the data is super important but I think
we overuse data and I'll tell you one
thing I very much believe about data
data's post-game it told you what
already happened
and I think we need to innovate more on
our intuition and start using more EQ in
this industry than just IQ Dan just said
he's given 500 bucks to the next person
ask a question awesome and Congrats Dan
I'm waiting for that but I don't what
you mean Craig cause like at Conde Nast
how are you hey Craig how are you um
quick question so yeah what you just
mentioned is really interesting right
it's the idea that you know somebody can
see the kind of direct results that my
content has you know Green Mountain
Coffee they can see on the cups so for a
larger purchase item right where think
about autos for instance it's like
average like you know use eight to ten
different sources to actually buy your
product and you're only making that
product purchase once every couple years
for a higher ticket item how do you how
to use an attribution model right to
kind of go back to are you actually
getting lead gen are you actually move
vehicles so this is like the most
interesting question for me in the whole
space especially around social in the
content within it the answer is you use
the same model used for everything else
right it's a impression
somewhere along the decision-making path
right and so a lot of people come to me
and like well what's the ROI of
the social media content we're producing
and then I'm always asking them cool
like awesome and and this was a real
question for me asking them because I
was just getting into the industry I'm
like well how do you do it for outdoor
media how do you do it for your print
how are you doing it for your
commercials and the answers were
straight garbage [ __ ] right I
started like calling my you know nerd
[ __ ] friends at MIT and they're like
this is [ __ ] math I'm like right and so
like you know so the funny thing is is I
Sai continued to try to figure out when
they ask me that question why they don't
have an answer for any of the
traditional [ __ ] other than [ __ ]
Nielsen's told them you know is it's you
know it hurts right you know you like
like the math that I have a national I
have a big television client and they're
spending so much money on outdoor media
right and I'm like cool I'm like by the
way as you're debating my scope over
here for this [ __ ] nothing money that
you put in one [ __ ] billboard in
Kansas can you explain to me what the
ROI that billboard is and nobody's ever
got an answer
there's models there's things that our
industry has accepted you know your
company in the print business we've
expect accepted three times circulation
when I finally learned a couple months
ago what that meant was Oh Jane might
leave her [ __ ] Vogue in a bus and I
might come up pick it up and go to page
147 and see the [ __ ] Jaguar ad right
I was like [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up right
right eight respect a good brand right
so you know I mean I I think that a lot
of things have been accepted in this
world and it's funny you know now that
I'm not in my wine shop which is over
there in New Jersey every time I come
once every two three months
everything's broken when I was in it it
all seemed right I'd been in it my whole
life you know I I was so successful but
it's like [ __ ] with a new eye it's like
so many thing
were flawed the things I've learned from
other areas I feel like I walk around in
this world and I'm like wow how like wow
right
you know you come with fresh eyes I
think that there's a lot of [ __ ] that is
being accepted that is not true I mean
you know some dudes stood at the top of
that building collect how many cars
drove bike
multiplied it and came up with a price
for the billboard that's on you know ii
mean it's ridiculous you know as i told
that client and i like to say in
keynotes and some of you've seen this
you know when you drop when you you know
we're in new york so you know a lot of
you might be from the west coast when
you're home when you drive the next time
watch how many people out of the five
people you drive past are on their cell
phone while they're driving at least
three of the five at least so i always
tell my clients i'm like people aren't
looking at billboards they're not even
looking at the [ __ ] road anymore and
so i think it's every person in this
room's job to care about one thing where
are the eyes and ears of the end
consumer and the eyes and ears are
shifting that last panel they're clearly
in mobile but very honestly I've been
like obsessed with mobile for the last
four years it's all I think about most
of things I investin try to figure out
how to storytellin it but now very
honestly after playing around with
Google glasses I'm like [ __ ] I'm like
all right now this right and so like
what's gonna happen when somebody goes
into a supermarket and my clients
product has some bad news on it and when
they look at it it's physically gonna be
there and giving them information about
the recall or why it's not healthy I
mean you know it's we're not gonna need
McDonald's to put the calories on the
sign we're gonna get it if we want it
based on the apps we put on our Google
glasses and that's 36 months away it's
gonna be here in a heartbeat so at the
end of the day we can talk about tactics
in here all we want and we should be
executing because it matters but I think
there's a philosophy shift that needs to
happen overall which is we have to start
from the consumer not from us I think
there's way too much us talk and us
think what we want what's good for us
this will be good for us if this happens
if you reverse engineer what they want
you have a far better chance of the
conversion that we're all looking for
cool yeah
No
not even close I thought it was trying
to be good because they didn't know most
of the people in here hey Gary its Ryan
Charleston from oppressive how are you
good God
there's a lot of talk about agencies and
the role they play in native advertising
storytelling obviously that's what
they're good at yep
and how publishers are kind of
encroaching on that territory
yeah doesn't this though put them back
sort of at the center who the baby
agencies listen very honestly and I said
it when I was in the wine business I
talked I sat in front of a room like
this in Napa with a hell of a lot more
people I said in 1999 I said listen I'm
starting to do a lot more business on
this thing called ecommerce that you all
think is stupid and I'm like you better
not make the mistake of me having more
value than you all of you in this room
should start selling your wine
direct-to-consumer
because if you do you're gonna keep a
hell of a lot more of the money to me if
vaynermedia my agency does not bring
value to my client we should be out of
business so should everybody so the
answer is you can't just say agency
it's like saying social network some
suck [ __ ] and don't deserve the business
some are good and are bringing more
value because it's really funny that's
another thing that I've learned about
this agency thing since I decided to
start one I can't believe all ours all
ours are treated equal I get on the
phone with procurement and they're like
well this or like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about like that company is [ __ ]
like I'm doing good work and I get more
value for my hour if it's quality and so
I think that's what it comes down to I
think that I think that publishers
should play very honestly I'll give you
an algal really rogue on you on this
question so if you look at data which I
love so much if you look at data in the
nineteen in 1982 the percentage of MBAs
that went to CPG clients versus retail
that went to Proctor and when all the
way up into the early 2000s everybody
went to Procter and PepsiCo and
companies somewhere around 99 2000 you
started seeing an interesting shift
where a lot of people started going to
retail and more importantly the creme de
la creme were starting to go retail so
over the last thirty years the amount of
money that brands have put into working
media versus trade has been stunning
if you look at the money that
tailors like Kmart and Woolworths and
all those guys got from brands in 1982
was nothing it was an afterthought when
you start looking at the money today
that the Walmarts of the cost goes and
what now amazon is asking for the trade
dollars it's stunning at the same time
those companies those Walmart's and
Costco's the amount of private labels
they had 30 years ago would non-existent
today there are substantial parts of the
business so brands are funding their
competitor their competitor isn't you
know you know libros competitor isn't
necessarily Cincinnati it's more
Arkansas than they think and soon to be
Seattle right so here is where I'm going
with this because you don't know why the
[ __ ] I'm saying this somewhere around
the time when the talent started going
to the retailer instead of the brand
something interesting happened I
actually think that the smartest brands
out there when they start winning the
creative battle and all of a sudden the
best creatives aren't going to startups
and maybe aren't going to fancy-schmancy
agencies but they're going to bran
direct and they become the best
storytellers I think there's a major
battle between the publisher the brand
and the agency and who's gonna win is
who's ever good at it right and so
they'll be a flushing out there's a lot
of below-average work out there at scale
that's gonna be fleshed out because the
innovations on people are paying
attention I think the number one
creative chick right now that is coming
out of school today may want to go to a
fancy agency here on some you know
Madison Avenue I think in you know three
four or five seven years it's gonna be
interesting where that gal might want to
go and it may want to be brand direct
every person every business every human
in here every brand smart what everybody
everybody is in the content war now
we're all in the content business and
it's all gonna come to a head and you
know quality is gonna win and whoever's
got the right strategy's gonna win
like breakthrough we've gotta have that
behind it so how do you guys approach
that so we don't play a whole lot and
paid as a company we do do a lot of
social media ad buying for certain
clients especially as paid has gotten
into content that's a sponsored story
thought process of amplifying at that
moment and you know if you haven't paid
in Geneva call him and email them but
you know you miss your moments you know
I listen I think paid is is great but I
also think that look it's funny I don't
think about it a lot to be honest with
you because it's funny to me how in this
world paid media is such a nice word and
non-working media is such a bad word
right
but the way I look at it as an
entrepreneur is paid as renting and
non-working is owning if you do it right
and so you know I understand the
amplification I think the I think the
pricing of most traditional at this
point is not in line to the reality of
what its delivering I don't think a
single person here how many people in
this room by show of hands outside of
live sports and the Oscars when they
watch their TV shows whether it's on
Netflix or or DVR the far majority of or
on-demand the far majority of the
scripted television they watch raise
your hand just curious how many of you
if you're watching scripted TV are not
watching it live when it's being
broadcast weird all of you how many of
you when you're then watching that
especially on DVR are fast-forwarding
every single commercial so to me that's
the interesting part right there's a lot
of paid that's just not being consumed
now I will respect scale and I I know
the conversation of scale and especially
I only work with fortune 500 it's all
scale conversations at all time but but
you know going to you know a 80,000
person arena standing there and yelling
your story but nobody's in those seats
is not achieving scale and so I think
there's a major shift in the marketplace
I think that people need to be more
entrepreneurial the more I realized
what's really happening is brand
managers this is the biggest brain [ __ ]
I got when I got into the game that a
brand manager like one dude and one gal
are running a billion-dollar business I
was like how the [ __ ] like I was like I
remember my first meeting with riding
gum I was all excited a Cadbury I'm like
oh man there must be like you know can't
we
Tiger team I'm like this you know we get
into a small room I was confused two
people walked in I'm like you're the
entire team you sell a billion dollars
worth of gum they're like yep I'm like
geez and and she I started like thinking
about like they're outsourcing a lot of
stuff they don't have time and so for
them to be efficient because they're
just human beings they're doing things
that are a little easier planned upfront
and scale becomes quite valuable
I don't necessarily think scale is
always right
I think scale for example is the way
that the u.s. used to fight their Wars
big bombs battleships I think marketing
looks a lot more now like the way we're
fighting our current war which is you
got to go to a village you got to find
the dude and you got to convert his 17
people and then you got to go to the
next one I think you know hand-to-hand
combat for brands is gonna become a
bigger reality and when they start
realizing that non-working dollars is a
good thing that that's entrepreneurial
that that's something you can own and
remark it to and continue to market to
and drive your impressions down over
time I think there's gonna be an
interesting shift over the next decade
or or not yeah one more sure what's your
name ma'am how are you good Jeff
we talked a lot about you know solving a
problem first and you know actions that
engage consumers take place after you're
helping them do something what do you
think the implications are for that
around a CPA or CPE model as opposed to
you know you you're running a pageview
where there's an action they could take
place and if they do they're gonna be
happy and you solve a problem but they
don't need to and the reason I bring
that up is you know Google's got a huge
liquidity trillions and trillions of at
avails right all these keywords right
but you may not have enough to to
generate that on a CPA or CPE model so
how do you how do you think about
translating an action native campaign to
a non impression based model you know I
don't know if I'm getting answer a
question properly because it's
interesting to like once you said Google
like it's funny where my mind went
while you're asking a question which is
the thing that most that I'm most
passionate about is trying to understand
where the markets gonna be 12 to 18
months because I feel like it's not too
far out but it's far enough that you
know I'm still being practical but I'm
I'm not getting too far ahead of myself
I am completely fascinated by a lot of
the case studies and the work we're
doing on a certain consumers especially
when you start hitting around 25 and
under about how they don't even see
certain things on websites you know the
debate of like there's an interesting
study coming out of Stanford that the
average 25 year old and under doesn't
even see the right side of a website
because that's where they know the
things that don't bring them value I
think we wrote I think the way I thought
about as you're asking questions
I think we've ruined ads the way they
look I think we have to take a pretty
rogue attempt the reason QR codes don't
work in the US is the first hundred
thousand QR code campaigns that rolled
out here were for videos of the
commercial for that brand there was no
reason for anybody to do it and once
they did it once or twice they're like
this blows I'm never doing a QR code
again and we got into that trained
action I think that there's a bigger
shift going on I think we apply old
marketing habits to the new platform you
go look at the first hundred television
commercials and their radio ads because
that's what we did when I look at banner
ads on mobile devices I'm like what
though you know it's it has no value and
so I think I think the reason native
matters so much is I do think content
the church the line between church and
state has been so crushed people are
willing to trust you as long as you
don't [ __ ] them with it and so they're
caring less about that I at ESPN and
Nike are competitors right this second
and maybe don't realize it yet or they
do and they're just setting themselves
up for it
I think Nikes gonna be producing content
and we'll have a Nike you know channel
wherever that may live whether it's on
television or the web and I think ESPN
is gonna sell sneakers and so I think to
me when I when I think about that
question the the the mechanism to
deliver those ads I think have been
spoiled very similarly to a QR code and
I don't think they get revived it's why
I started betting heavily on social when
I started understanding the data around
email services I built my business on
email services email service open email
open rates last year dropped 12 percent
from 34 to 22 I mean colossal collapse
people are not opening emails anywhere
close because the one thing I know more
than the sun's coming up tomorrow is
this one statement marketers
ruin everything it's what we do we find
something we squeeze the living [ __ ] out
of it until it doesn't breathe right and
so how many people here signed up for
living social or Groupon or Gilt Groupe
or one of these sites do you remember
how you felt back in the day when you
first got on there you couldn't wait to
get [ __ ] $50 worth of sushi for $25
right you just couldn't wait but because
they ruined it because they didn't
target it well enough because they
didn't bring you any value cuz they
pounded you until it brought you no
value you now delete it without even
looking at it and you don't give a [ __ ]
if they're offering you a million dollar
home for a hundred bucks you're like
deleted spam get the [ __ ] out I believe
there's a far majority of the banner the
search the keywords the the mechanisms
to deliver these ads we talked about him
to me I think philosophically that's
broken so I don't think much about the
next step because to me that's broken
and so what's the next step
social became that but now I look at
like the engagement numbers and things
that have happened on Twitter you know
five years later and they're lower
because it's such a firehose that's the
brilliance of what Facebook realized
they had to do to keep their product you
know you know edge rank mattered right
if they were gonna show you everything
then you were dead and so I think
advertising is much more broken the
people think I think that it's that we
are wasting dramatically more money than
people think I am blown away by how many
people's ambition is to go to the South
of France
drink some [ __ ] pink wine and win an
award I'm stuck